everything is better in slow-mo the
slow-mo running is one of the most
iconic things about Baywatch and we
couldn't wait to put it in our movie
ready guys yeah conic Run is something
that all of us have been preparing for
the entire course of this film almost of
an arc watching there that's pretty good
no pressure what was it like doing the
quintessential slow-mo run lady's hair
red hair yeah yeah
and also that sort of determined looks
that you have to you dream Lee
determined to save the honey but in a
very sexy way I think it went great
that's beautiful
it was my idea with the director at
least that's what he's trying to make
people believe I think he is just be
cool
just be cool man why does she look like
she's running in slow now the reason I
believe in God
[Music]
you never forget the one who steals your
heart or the one Oh
who kicks your ass someday sheesh it is
happening our Beach and my balls say we
need to go over there and check it out
the bad idea Mitch we're lifeguards my
ball day is just thinking he's right
well my balls are saying [ __ ] that noise
let's go handle business
your balls are bullies they watch work
because we follow rules
this guy trainwreck
I'm never Odie and not a single [ __ ] was
given what a bet forms in the whole
world
good like if a human octa jet which is
impossible to be so cool like me there's
your cup don't Jack off on my sheets
just remember I'm always watching Leon
I'm doing
[Music]
All Things Considered being out of work
but that's good luck pick it up
we need search for more evidence check
steam for needle marks you want me to
check his taint lift his [ __ ] scrotum
and check his taint there is a taint man
it's a taint even look get closer
oh holy yogurt oh there's a hole that's
just a bundle of smile most of that do
not post ATS it's a head full of ball
set
[Music]
he's turned the canals into the goddamn
X game it's because we were in lifeguard
pursuit oh okay
love it except for there's no [ __ ]
such thing as lifeguard pursuit
[Music]
you